at a hospital in Gaza Palestinians mourn
their dead funerals were held for a
pregnant woman and her 14 month-old
niece both killed on Saturday the girl's
father blames Israel the children were
playing and they were struck by a
missile shot from an Israeli drone an
Israeli spokesman denied that the
defense forces the IDF were involved and
said the Palestinians themselves were
responsible the unfortunate death of
that woman and a baby were not a result
of IDF activity rather a result of the
use of weapons by terrorist
organizations in that area in the
southern Gaza Strip Israel says it's
targeting what it calls terror elements
in the Gaza Strip pinpointing farm
buildings cars and high-rise buildings
in Gaza City the Israeli government
insists the strikes are in response to
Hamas and Islamic Jihad firing more than
600 rockets across the border into
southern Israel this weekend many were
intercepted while still airborne but
some landed in residential areas
destroying homes injuring and killing
civilians hastily declared in the early
hours of the morning the latest
ceasefire has averted an all-out war but
with tensions high it won't take much
for the violence to flare up again
let's bring in correspondent Tanya
Kramer who has the latest from Jerusalem
so Tanya we've heard that this ceasefire
has been in effect for a few hours now
how is it holding up so far well it
appears to be holding since the early
morning hours there have been no Iraqis
being fired into southern Israel from
Gaza and also there have been no more
Israeli air strikes on Gaza a
Palestinian media have reported that as
of a 4:30 a.m. the ceasefire has
and to effect a ceasefire that has been
broke at this time again and mediated by
Egypt with the help of Qatar and the
United Nations and Tania we know that
one of the main sticking points one of
the things that really sparked this most
recent conflict was the Palestinian
officials in Gaza were saying that
Israel was not taking steps to ease its
blockade under promised ceasefire deals
of the past how likely is it that now we
will see some steps to resolve this well
it's all about the implementation as you
said Hamas and Islamic Jihad another
militant group in Gaza they have accused
Israel of failing to implement
understandings that have been reached
during the last time there was an
escalation it was in late March and also
at earlier terms we've seen many of
those escalations flaring up over the
past year though and we understand that
this time also the ceasefire or calm is
based on those understandings that have
included previously the lifting of some
of the restrictions on Gaza like
expanding the fishing zone getting in
eight money from Qatar the flow of more
electricity into Gaza now it's really
all about this implementation but it
also shows that without a longer-term
plan or solution political solution for
the Gaza Strip which has been under a
blockade and has been under closure for
over ten years now it's it's gonna be
highly likely that we see possibly other
times of escalation Tania given the
tenuous situation there right now what
is the mood well I think people on both
sides are waiting to see actually to
know a bit more about the understandings
being reached I think in Gaza there's a
sense of relief it's also the first day
of Ramadan today it has been very
exhausting a weekend there and people
really would like to see that some of
those restrictions are being lifted now
in the south of
as well so many bars of rockets have
been launched against communities there
are people have been confined mainly to
their houses to their safe rooms but
they also would probably like to see
what is the result of all of this is it
just a period of calm and waiting for
another escalation or will there be some
some real solution at the end Tanya
Kramer in Jerusalem Thank You Tanya